(audience clapping)
Fun fact, I heard you like Mondays?
I do like Mondays.
Catherine, I love Monday so much.
Why do you love them?
I love Mondays because usually, I feel good after Friday
that I put everything, it organize everything
so that I can enjoy my weekend.
And so come Monday,
I was always taught
that you can always change the path of the way you feel.
And if I feel bad about myself,
I can start fresh in a Monday.
I love my, in fact, I have something to show you.
I just figured that proof would be better than me saying it.
Watch this.
(Drew gasps)
Mondays.
Mondays!
(bright upbeat music)
Mon,
Mondays, exclamation point.
Mondays!
(comedic record scratch)
(bright upbeat music)
Mondays, Mondays, Mondays, Mondays, Mondays, Mondays!
Mondays!
(Catherine laughing)
(audience clapping)
I filmed that at the beginning of the show
because I love Mondays so much.
We as human beings love
a New Year's Eve, a January, a birthday.
We need these little calendar markers
to say we get a clean slate.
And I think we get one every Monday.
Yeah. I'm with you.
Now when you hit Monday
and you're going to the set of this new awesome show on Fox
called "Prodigal Son",
where a fellow Welshman, Michael Sheen
is also on the show.
Yeah.
We actually have a clip of it.
I'd love to show it too if you don't mind.
Take a look.
(wet mop splatting)
(light footsteps)
Oh, Dr. Capshaw-
Not now.
I just have a-
I said, not now.
Vivian,
please.
(dramatic music)
(light footsteps)
Don't call me that.
Sorry, but I cannot stop thinking about the other night.
(intense dramatic music)
Neither can I.
It was a mistake.
(Catherine growling softly)
(audience clapping)
This show is so A-list.
It's just incredible.
It's so elevated.
Are you enjoying being a part of it?
I am, coming into show
in the second season
and people were like, "Why?,"
and I said, "Well, there's a few things."
I saw the first series and I enjoyed it.
And I watched it
because Michael Sheen is from my hometown.
Yes.
He's been in my bucket list.
This kind of like ever, ever, gets heavier and heavier
and heavier as the days goes on bucket list, bucket list
of some an actor I wanted to work with.
One, because he's literally from my hometown.
And Drew, it's like the tiniest people on the world map.
And our parents know each other,
but we'd never worked together
and we'd never met.
He was in the drama department of the local community
and I was in the contemporary downs compartment.
And so
it was like, why haven't we met?
We know so many people that we've,
since childhoods since we were like 12 years old.
So I wanted to work with him
and the producers pitched me this storyline
that was just so much fun as an actor to get my teeth into.
And then I could bring Michael Sheen
out of my bucket and go, "I want to do that with you."
It's been a lot of fun.
Well, I'm so glad.
And it really shows, and timing is everything.
And I'm so thrilled that you're a part of this
and that we can talk about it here on the show.
"Prodigal Son" airs Tuesdays on Fox.
And also, if you don't mind,
we're gonna feature Casa Zeta-Jones on our website
because I've been pouring through it
and it's just incredible.
Your whole lifestyle brand, it's expanding.
There's so much there already.
I have your products and your coffee here,
Thank You.
You're website is beautiful
You're so sweet.
so we're gonna throw to that as well.
Oh, that would be wonderful.
Cause we're all about Casa Zeta-Jones.
Thank you so much.
And thank you, Catherine Zeta-Jones.
"Prodigal Son" airs Tuesday on Fox.
And be sure to get all of your lifestyle needs
over at Casa Zeta-Jones,
your extraordinary lifestyle brand
(bright upbeat theme music)